Les Yo-kais sont tout autour de nous,
Mais personne sur cette Terre ne peut les voir,
Sauf un jeune garçon,
Nathan ! Bonjour mon chéri !
Coucou Mamie !
Tu ressembles comme deux gouttes d'eau à ton grand-père
Quand il avait ton âge, même si c'était un garçon qui avait aussi ses petits secrets
Ecoute-moi attentivement le monde
court un grand danger
Mais ? où elle est ? où est ma Yo-kai Watch ?
Les Perfides ont remonté le temps et changé le cours de l'histoire
Et aujourd'hui c'est comme si la Yo-kai Watch n'avait jamais existé !
Bientôt toutes les choses et toutes les personnes auxquelles tu tiens
Dans ce monde disparaîtront à leur tour
Nous pouvons toujours remonter le temps jusqu'à son époque !
Nathaniel je te présente Nathan, ton petit fils !
En avant !
Maximum !
C'est, c'est lui mon grand-père ?
Nathaniel il faut que tu finisses de fabriquer la Yo-kai Watch !
Dans le futur la Yo-kai Watch a céssé d'exister
parce que tu a arrêté de la mettre au point.
Alors mon concept va fonctionner ?
Si tu achève la conception de la montre
Ensemble nous viendrons a bout des perfides !
Jibanyan !
Nathan au secours !
Nathaniel est faible la Yo-kai Watch ne sera jamais
fabriquée !
Médaillon yo-kai activation !
Massacrez-les, Pulvérisez-les !
ça va faire boum-boum !
Maudit chat !
Pourvu qu'il aient des barres de chocolats !